hey what's up guys thanks for tuning in
to are you garbage please make sure you
go subscribe to the youtube channel that
way you get the videos
as they come out yeah do it
welcome to another exciting edition of
are you garbage the show where you find
out if your favorite comedians are
classy individuals
or absolute trash now
here are your hosts kevin ryan and
h foley hey
everybody out there and welcome back to
everybody's favorite new podcast
this is r u garbage the show we sit down
with your favorite communities do you
find if they grow up classy
or if they're absolute trash i'm your
host stage foley coming at you on a
beautiful day here
first episode back 2021. aunt tooty is
not here she's out at walmart
returning presents some of them not hers
we talked about it but she's doing it
anyway so i'm expecting a call from
local law enforcement any minute if i
had to jump up and leave
my co-host you picked these story lines
and no one else co-signs by the way yeah
you're not jumping up pal
you're slowly rising my co-host is
coming at you from right next to me
which tells you that uh we have a little
company in the studio today
um this gentleman right here he cooks
the books he put the whole thing
together he got the brand new mics ready
to go for us shout out to rhodes
street road that's right ladies and
gentlemen give it up for kevin james
ryan come on now
tippy's here hey hey gang what's up
everybody thanks for tuning in
as always happy new year first of all
yes sir guys please make sure you rate
review subscribe on itunes full video
available on youtube
subscribe there those numbers are true
to [ __ ] roof dude let's go let's get
to more true to roof um also patreon
baby patreon.com
are you garbage uh we just passed our
second goal of 400 patrons we're cooking
on there baby we just put up
wait a minute wait hold on do you smell
that
smells like patreon cooking oh my right
holy [ __ ] kippy look out
the big guy got a little rusty on the
beach i gotta tell you hey look at my
finger ready
guys go to patreon.com we just posted uh
we we did a cribs
uh a cribs edition of foley's childhood
home which is [ __ ]
fantastic that's on patreon.com go check
it out yep
and uh with that said shout out to the
old magic man the chicago kid
[ __ ] mr deep dish himself [ __ ]
t-bone toby mcmullen everybody our
producer extraordinaire
hey mike too look at him with the handle
and everything uh
dude i got a handle on my mic you guys
got mike's designed for voices
this is getting wild yeah we're really
cooking over here oh
we got a trash can in the studio too oh
it's 12 bucks
i'm sitting right here you [ __ ] prick
talking about me
they both made the same joke i didn't
know if i should be quiet and i had one
earlier than i
[ __ ] did the gun if this guy puts on
a couple hundred pounds i can [ __ ] be
out the door in two minutes folks we got
a little company today
if you haven't seen this episode make
sure you go back and check it out we had
him on a couple weeks ago
you'll love him you wanted him back he's
part of the [ __ ] argue garbage family
you know him you love him give it up for
ian
finance everybody hey
happy new year fellas happy birthday to
me i appreciate you guys
messages thank you wait it's your
birthday
it was the 31st why we're on the subject
oh you're a new year's kid
yeah baby dirtball ian yeah we have a
little present for you
shut up shut up
i didn't know anything about it yeah
well it's from all of us and fully
contributed clearly
yeah shut up yes are you serious what
did you get him i didn't transform
from port authority oh my god holy [ __ ]
i'm already salivating
brown paper bag yeah happy birthday
buddy oh my god this is so sweet
[Applause]
i asked for a carton every year for
christmas
yes and every year your mom tries to
steal you one
and gets caught that kid at amp's quick
my grandmother used to steal turkeys or
macbeth she had a brain tumor forgot
what she put it under her hat what do
you mean say she has a brain
in the car and they go missing she's
like i have a brain tumor
she didn't have a tumor i uh i asked for
a softback and the guy looked at me like
i stabbed his kids and i was like those
will be fine oh my
[Laughter]
he took the cellophane off and the
tinfoil and packed them
will be selling those for two bucks oh
my god right in front of times square by
the old tickets
oh my god who needs two i got two people
used to bum them off of me for money i
was like well i'm just selling my pack
one they're like i don't smoke what's
wrong with you we've mentioned this on
the podcast i think last time
you were a real derby you do one of the
most garbage things with cigarettes
you'll have cigarettes you'll walk up to
somebody you'll ask for a cigarette take
that cigarette
and then put it in your pack yeah well
like a russian soldier
you never know when you're in a bad
situation you might need one more bernie
to say goodbye
i need one four to the five so
could i give you guys a gift yeah let's
gift it up there you go well foley's
foley's on a very strict diet which
i mean you know oh i can tell i love how
did you do in hawaii
what's that i love you and that you're
financially great man
i loved you in that movie 12 sandwiches
12 years of sandwich also what's with
this vest you look like the world's
fattest financial advisor
bernie pork off barney pork loin
i don't want to put all your money in
rib eyes holy's written
[ __ ] jet skis on the beach oh my god
yeah you came back with a whole new
personality dude i don't even know who
you are
yeah you got a good head of hair you
shaved the head you got a vest and
you're wearing neon green
you got gray in your beard probably from
walking to the beach
also by the way he went for the listener
if he went to hawaii and he would
facetime me or like send me videos or
whatever and every time he was in a
parking lot and i'm like
who goes to hawaii and ends up in a
strip mall i like to keep my ear on the
street
i got face facetimed at 3am in a parking
lot
from hawaii dude he stays in parking
lots
and it's so funny because andrew schultz
schultzy was out there too like
swimming with dolphins and on the top of
volcanoes i saw dolphins
the miami dolphins and they didn't cover
if oh he's like anybody she talked to
bounty hunter
you gotta get off the ice bruh well he
called me facetime the other day and i
heard cyrus i did the dog tour what of
it
find out where he gets his coffee this
morning this is where he tackles
rednecks
oh i got my dog dude talk about his stun
gun in my in my
car i didn't even know they had parking
lots in hawaii meanwhile foley just
lived in them oh my god he finds the
only applebee's i want to see if it's
different
they put pineapple on their mozzarella
sticks it's fantastic
listen i did a lot of nature's stuff man
i was out in the [ __ ] jungle i was in
the woods
i [ __ ] saw whales breach would you
look in the mirror
this is a hotel pool but still
a couple of fours from cleveland
swimming around in there
afternoon ladies can i interest you in a
sugar-free
my time
you mind if i work on my cannonball
[Music]
fully looking for an adult swim at the
hotel
i'm trying to get my laptop's goddamn
kick you were making fun of me because i
had goggles on
he was wearing who wears who goes to
hawaii and wears goggles dude that is
what are you doing this ain't the
[ __ ] motel six hours
under the water and let me tell you
something don't put goggles on when you
go in the ocean
because it's [ __ ] terrifying what
even in hawaii thought it was all
it's crystal clear yeah that's what i'm
saying it's krista kuda you can see
what's going on down at the bottom
no what he saw those toes for the first
what the time is that i want his teeth
swimming around with goggles on all the
servers are like sure
like that's a weird looking blob fish
i think it's that piece of that big
floating trash island off we gotta get
this plastic out of the ocean in the
pacific
people are taking pictures on them and
stuff
yeah i saw whales breech
i saw waterfalls i saw rainbows with the
pearl harbor
[ __ ] that was sobering why
what do you mean why because they
wouldn't let you drink it on the base
sarah put the schlitz away
these little sons of [ __ ] only tries
to go fishing
it's like becca's vacation where can i
get some damn bait
give me a little bit of the yellow don't
skimp on me
oh god oh we're going to go to
the time we go too quick good times here
[ __ ] brand new year
brand new mic shout out to patreon.com
yes sir shout out to patreon.com shout
out to everybody
um for uh supporting us and showing love
uh big year plant's gonna be fun
ian's so happy to have you here in the
studio so happy he asked me to be here
we are gonna answer some patriotic
questions as we said it's a family app
we got treats we have presents we're
seeing each other after the holidays
absolutely fantastic time here at
antony's this is really nice thank you
yeah it's that yeah that's we're happy
we're happy you're here and thanks for
coming
i'm surprised you're not a carton guy
that you don't make in
making a make a a thing to go get
cartons i am a carton guy i do
you have cartons at the house three of
my apartments do you put them in the
freezer
oh that's a real trash move i have
buddies that keep them in the freezer
keep some of those pillows that's what
we do you used to do at the halfway
house
put him in the freezer shout out talking
about his mom's by the way
shout out to the emmett house newport
delaware the diamond of the north
wow you did halfway house in delaware
how do you tell the difference
oh look at this that's every house in
delaware yeah it's the quickest one to
draw here at [ __ ] aunt
dude it was across the street from a
bowling alley my mom threw me a surprise
18th birthday ad and i was
25 and like man if i could have looked
into the future then
holy [ __ ] oh by the way someone just
recently commented or tweeted
that they know the clown you were
talking about from the last episode shut
up bingo
go back and listen to you know just here
a month ago and we
tell a story about a client someone knew
the clown they go i know that [ __ ]
clown didn't you post a
pic picture no i sent it privately to
you guys it looks like a woman
it's one dude it looks it looks like it
looks like a [ __ ]
uh schnauzer with it the pain behind my
little four-year-old eyes it's just oh
yeah it's just
so hard i'll say this you've really
grown in yourself like if people say ian
looks weird first of all you got a tight
little body underneath there
shredded those pictures going around on
twitter yesterday
you as a little kid you look i mean you
you're just begging molest me
i was a cute little kid and then i don't
know i had it on my face for about two
decades if you were half frog
if you were a half frog half human you'd
be a cute little kid
you're a weird looking little kid what
yeah no i was the cutest little boy
i just shattered in what what do you
mean i don't know what bingo said
[Laughter]
look at this cute little kid you're cute
there you're cute there yeah
i'll give you that yeah but 80s like
when it really settled in the 80s you
were real
you looked ian dm that to me so i can
put it in that i will
i will you looked malnourished i think
that's well you know and then sometimes
you turn into this wow
dude you have multiple rows of teeth
you're like jaws i know
i it was bad i'd have braces twice he's
like a mako
yeah yeah it was a lot dude
it was a lie hey but you got that kiss
from sandy at the
public pool dude look at that cute
little kid
huh i get my muscles from my dad you
know
i and look i had an awkward face in high
school they said you're gonna be hot
when you're older who said that right
some girls at the lunch table
go back get back there now show them
what's going on
yeah as you can tell ian's totally over
it you have people that are actually the
names that hurt you oh dude this one
chick whoa wow
she really did one on me we we i got her
am name from a friend we were like aming
and we talk on the phone and like
you know say these like things she's
like i want you to i'm going to get you
chocolate boxers and i want you to run
over to my house how old is she
dude the boxers foley's got a pair on
right now bowler's like wait do you
still have them
all right seven everything's crispy's in
them seventh grade we made plans to meet
up at the italian festival did you go to
school with her
no she went to another school how did
you ever see her live in person
uh no but i heard she was hot you're
joking so excited
i swear to god we go to me i don't want
to name dropper
but um her name's no don't say it she's
a seventh grade kid you she's older now
it wasn't last week so it was two months
ago
so so we go to the italian festival
and we go on the zipper and she won't
talk it's the zipper
you don't know the zipper sounds racist
[Laughter]
yeah yeah yeah well you know it comes
with a free conical hat
so um what's the what is it though the
zipper you know the zipper
i don't know it by the name describe it
it's the carnival ride that has those
little cars and it goes
up and down it spins around that's the
salt and pepper machine you [ __ ]
[Laughter]
the extra sugar
how tall do i need to be to ride this
ride oh it's for everyone's son
that's the day that i knew i wanted to
be a kearney
this is a zipper yes that's italian
just giving them racist names yeah
that's all right they had the zipper
at a bunch of different festivals at the
[ __ ]
you know my favorite ride was here goes
the neighborhood
they got two tickets for the you're not
dating my daughter
yeah i dude my favorite ride was you
don't mix
[Laughter]
you stay with your own kind was a fun
one listen
uh all right so you get on the zipper
the pepper machine whatever yes
all right the zipper god delaware
delaware is [ __ ] trapped oh yeah it's
the best holy [ __ ]
you get on the zipper she won't talk to
me and then
she because gotta get a hot sausage
sandwich and call my mom to pick me up
and i'm like this is weird
so then later wait hold on say i'm sorry
she she goes i have to go i don't feel
well and she called her mom from a pay
phone to pick her up and i was like huh
how'd you guys get there
so our moms dropped us off individually
or you picked her up
it was it was like a blind date in
seventh grade
it was like yeah yeah and like we went
with friends and whatever whatever
and then dude i swear to god you know
how they were like um
forwarded chain emails when you were
younger those like all about me
whatever's
and there was one that was like when you
hear this person's name what do you
think and like i'd gotten it before from
like our group of friends
and then it was like mark henry kevin
you know t-bone and uh she
sent it out and she added the name ian
and next to it was like
short vampire teeth curly hair
gross big nose like all this stuff about
me and i was just right on the money
jesus christ your girl's got a [ __ ]
smart head on her shattered
this is after the zombie after we met
when she saw me for the first time
like the next day so she saw that for
the first time yeah
and like you were a cute kid this chick
had a honking guy
she had a honker i mean she looked like
toucan sam in a jewish box that's her
blowing the horn trying to get you out
of the front of the car
smoke is sick in a rainstorm she was
you know and she'd get a nose job later
and then you know i heard you like
i had a rough time in high school so
you're done who's got vampire teeth
with a free pack of burnies too i know
what are you having
she could have been splitting that pack
of marble lights with you right now i
know you're trying to sell lucy's on the
street
huh yeah oh man all right okay italian
festival
but i'm grateful for it because it made
me into the man i am today yeah
ruined in my body i'm a handsome fella
and a [ __ ] nut case
yeah well you always know ian's like
being a bad he'll call you out of
nowhere and be like
hey this is what's going on in my life
and you're just like which i love
i love it he opens up with how you doing
yeah are you doing you go oh not bad you
wouldn't say
well my mom won't do this my [ __ ]
wiener's filling up i keep blowing guys
oh dude
my my buddy which i enjoy but i'm just
saying my buddy the other night i go hey
man what's going on how you doing and
you talk for a minute and goes
now that we've gotten rid of your little
five-minute listen
what's going on
yeah he'll call me be like oh i saw the
schultz thing that's great that's great
that's great
well here's what's going on with me
he's like a greek mobster he doesn't
like to start business right away
would you rather be open with with the
no i'm crazy
i love it i always answered the phone
calls we talked to last week that's
right
i like to listen no i know no it's true
it's true it's just very
it's just funny most of my phone calls
with you and listen if you need anything
give me a call anytime yeah that yeah
that's usually not a great then i do
and you don't like 10 minutes later like
when people were like we should get
coffee the next day i'm like you want to
get coffee no i was being pleasant
yeah my mom's got to pick me up i'm not
feeling well yeah yeah yeah get off this
zipper
dude i need to he's like if you need
help moving let me know and then like 20
minutes
20 minutes later he's text me you find
anybody who need help moving next
morning you need help moving i'm good
are you i
just broke my ankle he was like i'm like
dude we got it it's all right
it's okay i'm trying to get back i love
it
i'm trying to get the money i borrowed
that i don't have so i'll do manual
labor in your apartment
that's awesome we're square after this
though right
you never showed up steer like the
intention was there
buddy so happy to have you here let's
get to some [ __ ]
that patreon is on fire we love you guys
we love everybody in the facebook group
two we're gonna yank a couple of those
uh good times yeah guys so as a lot of
you know when you join the patreon
uh because we get so many people you
know have so many ideas for garbage
questions that they
send us comment uh whatever whatever we
just can't get to them all so when you
join the patreon we will ask one of your
garbage questions
and that's what we are doing now this is
one that hits home to me
uh after the first of the year this is
from robert reed and the patreon what is
the longest you've
driven with bad inspection stickers on
your car
cause as of the end of december kippy is
riding dirty
wow the last time i was home i had to
re-up my mom's
really oh it was a while yeah
she was riding dirty she don't care yeah
no it's just a post-it on the front of
the windshield
and i owe you yeah well i've never been
pulled over but can't won't they give
you like
hey i'm on my way there tomorrow i got
an appointment next year but they don't
give a [ __ ]
yeah they still write you up especially
now they need the money for the state
local federal authorities [ __ ] bad
news you look like one of them yeah
you look like you would you look like
farva
somebody get this guy a leader of cola
i hose him off
but i went home for christmas and they
were like i didn't i don't even look
like that's the thing in new york
like my car is like an uber it's like i
don't use it it's just there and then
like yeah
yeah i don't use it for two weeks did
you get pulled what you get pulled over
no no no i i didn't but i went home and
my mom or my mom texted me she's like
dude
when did did you get your car inspected
because it's still registered in pa i
gotta
get it inspected in pa sure so i'm like
no i did it and she's like
you got to do that so i'm home myself i
was like oh what are you doing tomorrow
i can
send you down to nix and he can take and
i'm like i'm not but then i get in that
car and i'm like i still have till the
end of [ __ ] december
that's january's problem nothing so wait
how how
how long did you go well i'm currently
you got a high speed burn from here to
[ __ ] pa to get it done you can't even
get it done up here
why don't you get the car inspected in
new york become a new yorker yeah dude
do you have a new york license no what
still no
you've been here ten years jesus no i
haven't
eight seven but seven yeah i don't know
what's
it's just a [ __ ] headache no it's not
you gave me
so much [ __ ] about running a florida id
in illinois for like nine years
it's not even a driver's license though
you idiot you have an actual state
issued
a [ __ ] sleeper mine's a driver's
license let's get that established now
all right i
i do agree that kevin having a [ __ ] p
license is garbage buddy you have put on
a state id it's trash i don't care
i don't care if it's from the vatican
yeah that's garbage well you just get
out of county
at least get a passport be a gentleman
holy walk around
international bar hopper who doesn't
know how to [ __ ] draw who doesn't
have a [ __ ] driver's license what is
it
why would you get a state id because
it's got a [ __ ] barcode on your wrist
with you hey t-bone number 5497
reporting your duty sir
it's like a clone trooper truth be told
i lost the passport i was running for
about a year
okay i had to [ __ ] figure it out go
guys that's crazy to not have your
license as an adult is crazy too
unless you live in maybe new york but
still you get it yeah i would never walk
into a bar
confidently chicago [ __ ] [ __ ] yeah
chicago is not new york we've gone over
this
one you don't need well i mean you don't
need a license for that
right now i'm you and your hipster dude
just gotta be cool man
yeah the cops pull you over like are you
red
all right do an ollie right now yeah if
you do a kickflip i'll let you go
my mom was always on top of me about
that [ __ ] and it seems like yours is too
it's funny how they remember that stuff
yeah like i went home it was like a
thing that like my whole family had
spoken about that time like
i'm like what i don't i'll figure that
out later now you're a criminal you're a
wanted man
you know it's not street legal there's
going to be some work to go
i just i don't have the [ __ ] oh yeah
that's not passive yeah but you know you
know what's bad
the inspection whatever but if you got a
light out because that'll give them
cut you can only get the inspection
thing if you're like parked or they're
like really behind
you but the light thing and then they
they do that and then they ding you for
the other you're [ __ ]
then they find other things in the car i
know how you're thinking yeah
yeah all these dildos yeah yeah the
chick in the trunk i did one time
get pulled over on my skateboard by a
cop in chicago
it was the one i got pulled over on a
go-kart once
well i was going to wawa
i had to get a pack of bernies i was
opening for a tail and he likes to smoke
oh i love the family ups baby oh my god
everything's away from me i want to
smoke so bad well after
whoo a couple of hot bernies yeah pulled
over on a go-cart i got pulled over on a
bike
where are we going to go walking i was
just around my grandpa
he looks suspicious yeah what do you
mean yeah yeah this guy can't walk by a
police station without four or five
heads popping up behind oh that's where
i got my dui i
pulled over in front of a police station
in the middle of a four-lane highway
right foot on the brake left foot out
the window with a car and drive
sir you match the description of someone
who's about to rip off a motown
they asked me they're like ah what do
you got to rip off a motown
group mr barry gordon
sir what do you have publishing rights
to these songs
[Laughter]
is it true you only paid the temptations
100
paid them in backhands
all right that was fantastic question uh
this is from red palace this is
the time of the year and and you have
had to [ __ ]
maneuver this one have you ever tried to
sell for cash a redeemable gift card you
received from a relative
oh wow like did you ever have like a
macy's gift card the finances don't
strike me as a gift card family
no finance with money on it no well my
aunt camille
my aunt camille chili's meal my aunt
camille will give me a five dollar wawa
gift card and go treat yourself
to a coffee do a whatchamacallit
a couple now and leaders and hit the
bricks taking mary jane and get the [ __ ]
out of here
a five dollar gift card yeah when you
have multiple
multiple trying to make payment make a
purchase with multiple gift cards
i mean yeah it's in the name aunt
camille
and uncle clyde oh man
how much time did uncle clap uncle
clyde's got a rabbit link
yeah that dude's serving a nickel down
state
slip and fall money i remember one time
my buddy we were like younger or
something and i wanted to return
something to like not a gamestop but
something along that lines like
eb games or you know whatever one of
those things i was returning some sort
of technology like a controller or
something
some sort of technique and they were
[Laughter]
it's insane how little of room one of us
has to make an error
before the other two [ __ ] on them it's
dude you gotta be
perfect without getting to not get i was
at planet blockbuster
returning some alien technology when i
realized my gift card did not work
my sega cd was broken kippy's log 12 21.
game boy not working my unregistered car
it's registered by the way i did that
late too
you know you know it's trashy when your
registration and your inspection are two
different months
[Laughter]
oh yeah oh yeah
shout out to november and december
[Laughter]
oh man that's real garbage holy [ __ ]
you know you got to get back three days
later to get this registered right oh my
god they give you the ticket in a brown
paper bag
oh god i'm crying hey officer why don't
you get right to your ticket for the
registration too because
i've got a couple hours left on that
happy new year remember when you were
making fun of me because i was asking uh
i mean i'm sorry you're gonna have to be
a little more specific
i had so little money in my account one
time and it was about to be overdrafted
that i had i had to call a credit card
company and ask what time
of the day a day would take she didn't
understand me she's like oh we're gonna
pull it out today
i'm like yeah i get it today what are we
talking three o'clock four o'clock
give me a [ __ ] window here honey
is it like something you do in the
morning or at night
you know you're in bad shape when you're
bargaining for a couple of hours
do you take a long lunch what do you
usually like to do you bring something
yourself or do you go out
is that quarter of a quarter of ish
[Laughter]
i know it hits you today but like what
time typically oh
[ __ ] it was like [ __ ] pacific time
it was you an la gal what's the deal i
think that was
parking tickets too i think that's what
that was something something was coming
out god damn i got a judgment on my
i had to give up my car i had too many i
had a judgment on him from so many
parking tickets i
just i've i've been booed i've been
booted for yeah and that's like 800
bucks
dude the judge was too much parking
tickets i mean the car was going
judge the judge strikes the gavel this
guy stinks
the car was going i i my hood flew off
on the queensborough
i had to leave it on the corner in 60
seconds of burst
the [ __ ] blew yeah yeah
what i did last weekend and then the
judgments and i was like i'm out
bye camryn mr finance you are guilty of
being a dirt ball
this court is a germ
[Laughter]
get that hood out of my courtroom before
i go
you got a light i'm not a big city
lawyer nor do i need to be this is cut
and dry
i like in falls reality ian brought the
hood to the corner
i was carrying it down the street like a
sheet of drywall your honor look
at it the hinges are broken you're on to
the hinges it was all the hood your
honor i was just an accomplice
yeah fdmy guys are walking by with the
[ __ ] shirts i go can you help me go
[ __ ] you kept walking helping some
[ __ ]
interest you gentlemen in a uh in a hood
please
yeah thing flew right off on the
queensborough i
would have made a left off the bridge i
had to drive like ace ventura with my
head out the window
i i mean people are cell phone careful
what happened to your car that's none of
your damn business i appreciate
your nose out of my personal affairs oh
my god that sound
didn't crack the windshield dude ian
does the spin out all right
who's the her he's talking out of his
ass when the cops come
excuse me officer does anybody have a
breath mint
or a hood for a 94 corolla i'm actively
looking for an iron horn
could you turn your can you take your
pants off and turn around please wait a
minute wait a minute think of lasagna
i'm in mine horde is finkel pickle's a
man
fickle's a man dude you should do that
[ __ ] ah that's great good stuff oh my
god that's funny
look guys there's nothing wrong with it
you're not gonna believe this i'm a real
responsible driver who want to put this
mask on
[ __ ] gets real what's going on
my transmission is smoking somebody stop
me
my hood is on my windshield i need help
[Music]
man it's kind of hot in these corollas
[Laughter]
i'm so long away i turned my room into
an office
yeah big things are happening for ian
yeah
he just sits in there and smokes
[Laughter]
curtains or tails it's just you trying
to find that chick from seventh grade
it's got like [ __ ] pictures red yarn
everything yeah yeah if i retrace my
steps from the zipper machine your
parents own a furniture ship
do they yes all right cut that dump it
dump it
oh yeah got there cut that they used to
come to the restaurant and worked out i
wouldn't serve them cut that cut down
her name's mary anne she lives on 324
wait they did
come to the restaurant you worked at you
wouldn't serve them that sounds healthy
jesus christ look at you yeah i'm over
it now
totally i'm over it now
yeah you set a car on fire and i didn't
drop them i'll kill you
[Laughter]
i'm going to piss myself jesus christ
all right we've got another one this is
from ray
uh thank you ray when was the last time
you've been to a place that had a trough
as a urinal
because if you're hanging out in a place
where if you're hanging out in a place
with the big one
urinal for all people with ice in it ah
it's tough man
that's a lot a lot of times it's that in
europe and it's like me and some [ __ ]
me got our [ __ ] little schnitzels out
me and i'm uncut
schlonger next to you kippy does not
look good next to an
uncut piece how big is that nine
but nine at nine and a half
dude i was on the road with chloe we
were in north dakota and the restaurant
had
the door handles were guns they were
rifles
and then the bathrooms guys was uh
trucks girls was garages
and they had troughs that's pretty
clever though i gotta give them that
[Laughter]
i always thought it was trashy you ever
see when they have uh like
like either newspapers or like like you
know they have literature
above the urinal so you can like take a
piss and like read [ __ ] i kind of like
that though
outback yeah it's always like you know
you know some whatever cover bands
coming in next weekend
you ever see your face on the flyer
above the urinal oh yeah yeah yeah
that's a lot of times at the shop
actually shout out
oh yeah in new york there's no alleys
have
any of you guys ever gotten there's one
in like chinatown
for piss i've never no you can that's
the thing you can easily pee
in public you're getting busted for
[ __ ] peeing in public
you deserve everything you get yeah how
do you [ __ ] get caught it's like
getting caught jerking off dude come on
it takes a little bit
in public what get caught jerking what
do you mean no no like you're just
getting caught jerking off in general
i've pissed in public my entire life
same here i cheered i prefer it
yeah never get caught get caught what
are you an idiot especially if you got a
lookout man
you're set if you have someone on your
back oh no they start walking
up and keep it moving there i was a
lookout man korean
it's a fun game though yeah like oh
looking around yeah cool real quick
oh yeah noah's crazy to me i just went
down i went down the shore this weekend
and we were driving down and we got off
to go to a starbucks whatever the
starbucks ended up being closed i was
gonna get a coffee and take a piss
starbucks was closed but as we were
pulling out of the parking lot
there was a porta potty and i'm like
what are the chances of that
port-a-potty being open
and then you're like it's in the middle
of new jersey they just leave them open
because it's like
but it was clean as [ __ ] but like in new
york you see a port-a-potty there's like
five dead bolts they're locked yeah
that's what i'm saying but like yeah
it's like country bumpkins like who the
[ __ ] gonna pee in there when you have
a hat new york is so hard to go around
if you got to go to the bathroom because
especially now everything nowadays
regular times it's the best some
starting hotels where you can
well if you got an issue with going in
public you're [ __ ] yeah you know
yeah do you have that issue not at all
[ __ ] where i want when i want
to dump in the chipotle oh i have
yeah while i'm waiting in line
they won't know the difference what is
that slop check out ian's new hour
everybody
[Music]
[Laughter]
in three hours that's going to be gold
it's funnier if you're in a parking lot
and there's a whale preaching i've had
jet lag on it
oh [ __ ] oh man he's a little dusty ian
shot me a look on that one
you're dying on that hill fatty try to
come at me and my material
oh man this is for a mitch and this is a
[ __ ] home run because my parents
didn't mitch uh mitch is a good name did
you did your parents
growing up did you or your parents on a
foot spa do you remember those things
you put on
you plug in and it would bubble the
water oh
those things are fantastic that's super
trashy wow super
[ __ ] i had an uncle dicky who had oh
my god yeah really
yeah use it as a hot tub
made pasta with it two broads in it
it does rice unbelievable
it's like an air fryer putting epsom
salt on top
that's a ramen my mom had one of those
man and when she broke that thing out
you were either real sick or you were
[ __ ]
injured or something like that put a
couple towels down sit there with your
piggies in there while the eight team's
on
that's clean living that's really true
it got cold real quick though
and it was always obviously the threat
of electrocution because it was [ __ ]
you're plugging in a [ __ ] bucket of
water well by the way
foley's family has this weird thing with
electricity that i don't uh
it's super strong [ __ ]
[Laughter]
we learned when we did the cribs that's
on the patreon edition his mom unplugs
everything in the house when they're not
using it the washer the dry everything
gets dumped
vampire uh somebody somebody uh messaged
me about it we were talking about it
vampire
electronics or something like that
sounds like ian's screen name
this new band i'm opening for vampire
electronics next week
wait a minute wait a minute what the
[ __ ] is vampire electrical electronics
that suck out
the uh power when they're not even on
yeah i mean
that might cost you like three bucks a
month or so that's three bucks in
savings that we'll pass on to the phone
did your parents or grandparents ever go
uh my grandparents when you'd leave a
light on they go
you turn the light off what do you think
we run delmarva power and light
yeah a big one would you what
[Laughter]
that's just a guy on a [ __ ] on a
treadmill i like how trash you are you
think that
that's the only energy we got one what
do you work for pico that's what do you
want what do you think i work for pico
that or if you kept the door open in the
summer like if you ran out to the car or
the garage and you left the
like the door open it was what are you
trying to you're trying to heat the
whole
neighborhood trying to cool off the air
conditioning the whole neighborhood
would your parents or grandparents uh
not flush number ones
ah no no no no my grandparents wouldn't
flush number one
wow really thanks why save water
man that's [ __ ] trash
you put the seat down you know now
that's too much
i'm sorry that's crazy yeah that's real
trashy the footspot
i don't do it anymore
there's like a two liter mountain dew in
there there's ash and piss
do you smoke when you're pooping i was
you looking no poop and smoking no no no
that just smells like my dad my dad used
to do it like what
smoking in the house oh yeah he's still
wow my dad never smoked in the house
have you done it before though smoked in
the house no smoke's taking a [ __ ] i
have
it's the best
too much work aren't you afraid of ashen
on your dong
no i got a lot of space down there i got
a lot of clearance
what is this the jfk assassination that
would have been after your real special
ash
go down in out come back up there's a
second hasher and
there's a second asher in the sink if
you got it hanging
and then it comes off it's falling well
when i when i charlie rich you got it
hanging what the [ __ ]
you can't [ __ ] put it in your hand
when you're also reading the paper
no i was pretty smart yeah i would i
asked uh there was a sink right next so
i asked that is
trash holy [ __ ] i do i mean my hat my
dad's house was a smoke like
proper smoking household on the coffee
table i just got an ashrae
i'm so excited for the outside 2021 here
i
are you smoking in your apartment in in
the office i open a window i crack the
door i put a candle and i got a fan
you can't smell it it's great i love it
probably smells like an army recruiting
center
just sign here boy
it's foley do you have your desks facing
the door too
i bet you not up against the wall it's
like people have to walk in it's in the
middle of the room
a little chair on the other side so you
can pull your power moves at your cat
so what makes you think you want to work
here and how often do you nap
you have a swivel chair so you can spin
around on the cat
so you think you're gonna get fancy good
evening mittens
what's your cat's name sampson samsung
samson welcome to the wet food
negotiation
[Laughter]
dude i'm gonna can i can i go take a
piss real quick i'm gonna piss myself
can we yeah i'm gonna piss myself sure
okay uh i'll eat it because i'm hungry
but yeah
eat it so we can for the listener ian
had to take a little potty break so he
broke out the cookies that toby's
girlfriend made
they're actually fantastic if you
haven't seen them not sure what they're
gonna cut out but look at that little
trash cans
actually you know what the more i eat it
the better it tastes that's right
yeah yep right it's like a hooker's butt
[Laughter]
sugar-free gluten-free baby shout out to
all right this next one is from john boy
have you ever been kicked out or asked
to leave somewhere
that other than a bar because you were
drunk
yeah yeah where the halfway house
no they didn't know i was drinking water
um
mouthwash you were getting lister
twisted [ __ ] judy garland over here
jesus christ mouthwash yeah what's your
brand
uh scope yeah i like it nothing let me
tell you something
not obviously we don't want people out
there to consume it for alcoholic
purposes
but scope scope is something scope is
the luden's cough drop of the mouthwash
shout out to ludens
oh yeah we've well discussed it rude
dude
is all right man scope's like breakfast
you feel great it's like a it's like a
like a
like a wintergreen lifesaver i love it i
mean listen i used to drink it and i
don't even love it that much
how'd you take it over ice little straw
stir a little
neat a snifter scope
ice all right let me get wintergreen
neat when i was in high school i grabbed
a gatorade off my friend's
desk oh no so thirsty i was like okay i
have some of this and he was like
sure took a big sip full of [ __ ]
mouthwash
getting lister twisted on the sly wow so
gatorade and [ __ ] i don't know why
don't you just get alcohol right
hang on you're tricking yourself you're
going well i'm not drinking what's
mouthwash
ralph macchio did you say lister twisted
is that what is that was that a term in
your high school
chicago
i knew people that were huffing dust off
in the back oh
that's funny i know i know i know people
who were going around to air
conditioning units cutting the freon
line and filling it with trash bags
and selling it at parties no i may or
may not have been there because they're
called maintenance men rich guys
i may or may not be related to some of
them oh my god really
that's right and then they would put the
bag shut up
is a little something on there don't you
there's like a when i inhale like
it's called rustoleum yeah when i inhale
i feel like
something's coating my yeah it's called
heart disease
it's called plaque and the scope ain't
gonna get that stuff out
what says ice with triglycerides am i
right come on
they're sugar-free and gluten-free
they're not
good it's not true they're delicious i
feel like i'm going blind
he's got cataracts
start playing the piano his foot foot
just detaches
molly's looking up to the left
i want to thank our very special guest
ian financer coming in today
it's almost like toothpastey
it does taste like you just been
listener twisted
lister twisted the new fun game for the
whole family
have an alcoholic aunt knock her off the
wagon
lister twisted you got down on one knee
for
getting ice now you're cross-eyed for
lizard twisted
i got water on the brain you got lister
twisted
i couldn't pass my hearing test you got
lister twist
lost my license comes with a free
hospital gown
i'm 85 years old and i've been getting
listed twisted since i was a little girl
a guitar solo player
[Laughter]
yeah man i don't know [ __ ] she's trying
to poison us what is this like misery or
something like that
i [ __ ] told you not to eat them tell
her girl back to the drawing board on
those
oh my god it's like in the back of my
like roof and back i love them you just
[ __ ] on them for three minutes
well not the aftertaste that's part of
them give me give me a dunkin donuts
balancer
i need to crawl a stack i'm dying on
this oh he's allergic to anything that's
gluten or sugar-free
foley don't breathe into your mouth my
stomach is shrinking get me a sweet
little question yeah i need a new mousse
boosh
give me a little pinch of that yeah no
you gotta get this taste
oh my god really yeah yeah it's like
that it's like that's
annoying like that yeah he's pretty yeah
you're predicting
twenty jogging in hawaii i ate nothing
but [ __ ]
jogging yep i was jogging you hurt
yourself walking down the street today
and you think you need surgery
you did not job 25 minutes all the
pagery money is going to go to getting
you a cane
[Laughter]
we're gonna have to take this wall out
to get you out of here
that's coming out of the security
deposit all right i'll stick with the
sugar cookies
oh my god sugar free cookies i just got
a great idea for a patreon episode
we get ian drunk on mouthwash and we get
fully all the donuts you can eat yeah
i like it ian will give you 20 bucks to
do it oh man
we'll give you a pack of bernies and a
donut i have to listerine on me
[Laughter]
look at you you're like ben affleck
going at that dunkin donuts today
oh really yeah and i got donuts for us
and i left them on the train
i know you're digging through that like
you're like you're eating like you're
digging through the trash
you were definitely a squirrel in
another life
really cool energy yeah you got real
city rat vibes hail my food
i just mash it together and just inhale
it wow and i'm i thank god i got
metabolism or else i'd be you know
[ __ ] foley junior
i feel like that was coming to my
direction also someone in a youtube
comment is called
it's so funny they called me the small
one and i'm like i'm an oversized man to
begin with
but sitting next to him i look tiny i
love that when they turn on you the way
people refer to you you know what i mean
they don't say kippy or henry they'd say
the fat one and the the bald one yeah um
thank no you just opened the door for
them to do it all i appreciate that
we'll cut that out open the door you
can't fit through yeah
just open the door i'm gonna get stuck
in thanks a lot with my sugar cookies
all right this is from dougie b dougie b
is the guy whose stove we went to see
when i was a kid
my buddy doug shout out to dougie b his
family worked for whirlpool and we this
was a
whirlpool and the kitchenaid and they
got a stove when that when the
what was it called the glass where it
was like yeah it wasn't the
flame or the coil it was electric but it
but it was
like the surface just the ceramic glass
he's never seen one of these
yeah you might have seen it in a
magazine or on a television
what are you talking about she got a
bunch of chafing dishes going
dude sternos are big in our family party
that's smashing my one hand always stays
home like what if there's a service or
whatever or a party or something
she always stays back or gets there
shout out to the encouragement also it's
ready when you get it
she's handles it she handles this i
thought you meant stays there so no one
robs a house
oh my god you are yelling they got the
meatballs no no no whenever there was a
funeral we always designated someone to
stay in the house so nobody
took a took it no one comes over
[Laughter]
[Music]
well listen somebody finds out someone
in your family died and they know
where you live they know you're not
going to be home and they're going to
ding up the joints
what are you hanging out with the
bandits next thing you know i'm buying
backpacking
i'm buying back a clock from a pawn shop
no what
that's an old wives house they said they
would wait they would read the
obituaries for johnny and steve smith
then go oh the view the services are on
this day no one's going to be at the
house so they go rob the house yup
that's what it is i mean that sounds
pretty on the money to me
yeah yeah i don't know if people are
smart i mean i don't
do you know anybody that's happened to
truth old delaware baby well it would
have happened to ian but they they
ain't knew that because he was doing it
to people yeah was hanging
they were shark to the move yeah hiding
in the bushes they wanted
my grandma you know was a little hmm she
used to also tell her kids if they
didn't eat their vegetables a rag man
would come and get them a rag
man yeah there's a man that you said
your grandfather
collect dirty rags in the neighborhood
was that a real person and she lied and
said that guy is going to come again
wait wait wait wait
why would the guy collect dirty rags i
don't know he's a rag man what else
that's not a term i mean he's what else
well that was the same that's what they
would say
i don't know like you don't know me from
joe [ __ ] the rag man i got i don't know
what that means
because guys used to go around and
collect rags and clean them for you and
give them back
that was like their little they didn't
why wouldn't you yeah
back in the day long time ago what in
the 80s
no in the [ __ ] you know 20s 30s 40s
50s at ragman
did you ever see the rag man in your
neighborhood no no you'd gone out of
business
replaced by the sponge man yeah once
paper towels dropped he was [ __ ] out of
luck
bounty came and put him out of business
ah they're just throwing out these
towels
oh [ __ ] i work this neighborhood c
you're like sid from seinfeld who blocks
the cars
are you looking up ragman i did it's
coming up as a
it's coming up it's a dc comic by which
he might be a background guy
that'll be bad when marvel's getting
down there that was such a deep cut
i said he's a dc comic you guys
washington dc
he took it as a washington dc black
comic named ragman
and he said what does he play the laugh
at
holy [ __ ] for the listener ian just
[ __ ] threat a needle from a hundred
yards
damn shout out to the laugh house oh god
that was like an m m line from the mid
to 2000's what the [ __ ]
that's why they call a window pane huh
oh laugh houses they're doing a
wilmington club
i think i saw that it's gonna be bad
news when's the open mic
start lining up now as long as you got
those wings cooking i'm in oh
my god holy [ __ ] the best part of the
laugh house was cassie finally got a
feature week in the clothes
that wasn't my accent oh man he he is
the
oh i'm sorry i'm in pain what the [ __ ]
cassidy is the kiss of death
unsuccessfully he is a [ __ ] black
clown
that was also his laugh house name
i heard he was working for trump cumulus
nimbus coming
oh gosh shout out to our good pal tommy
and donald trump shout out i love you
pal
thanks for the bones shout out to djt in
that six hundred kids
he was trying to get his two stacks i
know all right this is from dougie b
and i think you this is a youth i've
heard you talk about this uh did you
ever eat it ground round as a kid
yeah i used to have birthday parties at
the ground round oh that's right
where bingo was he goes there's
something in there
penny a pound special what's that penny
a pound special he goes did you get the
penny a pound spencer sex
he spent two million
[Laughter]
penny a pound's got to be i guess it's
for whatever you weighed if you were
like 50 pounds you would pay
50 pennies and pay 50 bucks he said what
does it jesus
we steer clear to stuff like that that's
because
was it cheaper for henry just to pay
menu prices
only to take out a lien on his house
well he's down at the small business
bureau
i'll just order off the breakfast menu
thank you is it normal to have four
mortgages
oh i gotta i got we gotta run home real
quick i forgot to unplug the washer
can i have a half of order of mozzarella
sticks is that possible
penny a pound that's trash i don't
remember we never [ __ ] with it i
remember there was one the ground round
and you would hear commercials dude i
don't know we never [ __ ] can you do
the math on that right now i don't
remember that
you do the math on that right now how
much full he would pay penny a pound
he's not john nash what the foot is it's
a beautiful mind what are you putting
put him on the spot
can you do this really autistic i like
how ian comes in and acts like that's
like toby's intern
that's like the fourth request you're
not running on that what's going on
hey toby uh do me a favor crunching
numbers also before he before he leaves
here ian's gonna bum a sig off toby
i i put foley's weight into the
calculator on my macbook pro and it shut
off
blew up it just said zero e e zero
times ten it turned into a pc
um no so it would be four hundred times
a hundred so it'll be what
four thousand you weigh 400 i weigh 375
pounds
not after that holiday but wait wait
wait no not after any sugar freeze
if it's a penny a pound and it's 400
it's four bucks
what are you talking about there's a
hundred pennies in a dollar
so you're telling me he could go to
ground round and as much meat as he
wants for four bucks
that's what no this deal doesn't make
any sense that's why they went out of
business
they were living on clown money
the follies came in and knocked knocked
them out of business in a weekend
[Laughter]
all right which one you use the tough
guy huh
who's cutting the checks in this game i
don't know it was a it was a penny for
every pound of
meat you ate bill
wait no it had to be a penny a pound for
what for what you weighed what did you
weighed
no no it was a penny a pound of the food
no cause and here it is i got a penny a
pound
around you won't even a piece of steak
ain't even a pound
i think kids pay what they weigh kids
pay what they weigh
so if a kid weighed 35 pounds it would
be a penny for
it would be 35 it would be 3.50
what no a penny a pound
so yeah you'd be three dollars that'd be
like eighty nine if you had a 200 pound
kid they paid two bucks
yeah there you go all his family was
paying 80.
no that doesn't make sense it's a kids
meal it's like a kids eat free type
thing
yeah these are 80s advertising gimmicks
you wouldn't get them it was a different
time
we didn't know what we were doing all
right
jesus what do you want man
[ __ ] trial and error the goddamn
japanese were killing us every time
we had to [ __ ] do something the
[ __ ] the japanese you really were
affected by pearl harbor oh my god
oh i love this [ __ ] show oh dude the
way you
hit the japanese and the europeans are
all the japanese
were killing us i almost i was at a
seizure dude
that was so funny [ __ ] reagan reagan
was up against it huh you gotta get out
there sell
sell
it's talking
[Laughter]
our advertising in the 80s was real
loose made a lot of promises we couldn't
keep all right yo you're not going to
top what your cover
time magazine had a martini glass full
of cocaine and said i
told everyone it wasn't addictive shout
out to big cocaine
remember that i think you just made that
up look it up toby
told me you don't have that up yet what
the [ __ ] first of all there's not even a
monitor for us to look at that's from
from
january 16th 2011.
penny a pound is today from 11 a.m to
two people that's what i pulled up kids
pay
kids pay what they weigh lots of choices
and good atmosphere we are proud to be a
family
friendly establishment penny a pound
made it into the new [ __ ] millennium
dude
hope you kids like cigar smoke
[Laughter]
high on cocaine a drug with status
and menace uh and menace but they're
leading with the sexiness
martini glass full of coke man all right
let's we got a couple more here to get
through holy [ __ ]
that's what you were asking me to look
up i thought you asked me to look up
ground round
listen he's no jamie okay that was three
direct orders ago
that was three unruly demands ago
ian's gonna expect you have all this
transcribed by the time the podcast is
over too by the way
ian gets final cut too so what about
yeah
um give me my transcripts i'm leaving
it's so funny too for the listener ian
and toby have like an amazing
relationship
outside i love toby so much i just came
in and gave you a new band you got me
into pup
i had some of my favorite bands the
shirt you're wearing oh yeah
i wore this shirt for you today yeah
yeah and ian and i our our friendship is
based around flame emojis and instagram
dms
yes hey real life reddit relax will you
a couple of real athletes here huh
all right you guys supposed to be
fighting off the ladies
your black hoodies underground bands
grateful dead wawa hoodie
look at the back we do it just a little
bit
better at the carnival
ever get on the zipper ride um all right
here this one is from
uh marcus have you ever broken a video
game controller or electronic device in
a fit of rage
yes yeah wait is he asking if you've
destroyed any technology
[Laughter]
the technology was ruined
it's back to the civil agents lost in
madden and now mom
is mad i owe her allowance money my
jello pudding pops are now in jeopardy
for after dinner because i destroyed
the instrument that turns off married
with children
i'm as they say grounded and
my only hope is to build a time machine
and go back in time
and beat my cousin at nhl 95
if only i can break into the texas
instruments factory
ah i did not appreciate these jokes at
my experience
i i just i i cracked a [ __ ] do you
remember the game
jez ball it was on i was on windows
night it was on windows no i've been
making
it's under games what'd you say no i've
been making them
that's what i call the socket in the
corner of my room
that was my ex-wife you guys you guys
ever played jessica
and my buddy jim growing up
all your buddies stand in a circle
soccer ball he lays us a doughnut
dude i think i have a jerk off on a
hacky sack kicking around
i feel a lot pitching here you jerk off
on a hacky sack and kick it around
[Music]
[Laughter]
it was a different time it was the 80s
man
who knew what a hacky sack was we were
guessing we were getting meat for a
penny a pound
welcome back to the 1988 jizz ball
championship
brought to you by penny for pound at
ground round bring everybody in
that's molly's laugh house dave hacky
sack
give it up for a hacky sack how long
he's got one of those dr seuss hats on
he's dressed like reggie from nutty
professor yo
the [ __ ] dr zeus hat that became
popular
that was a question somebody wrote that
in i had multiple
i had different colors oh man i was i
were on molly
it was a classic rock cover band in
eighth grade and we all wore wacky hats
and the drummer to dr seuss
i see you really matured since then
you're called the bazooka joe experience
oh my god that never kissed a girl
experience
the left on the zipper ride experience
the multiple chest balls
the holy the hey a lot of guys do this
to each other
my cousin does it he says it's fine so
hurry up my dad's almost home
[Laughter]
experienced
there's something about this feels wrong
orchestra uh
[Music]
bazooka joe experience man yeah
yeah can you play an instrument i can
play guitar
and this and the skin flute
his front seat in the orchestra
and the african rhythm stick
oh god
oh folks we're having a good time here
at aunt toddy's
this one's all right we'll do one or two
more having such a good time that when
something doesn't land it's almost
deafening oh yeah and it makes me want
to quit the podcast
when i throw one out there and it's
nothing i do like well we're running so
hot that it's like as well i i need to
my brain needs a second to decompress
and i
zone out i don't even hear anything it's
like it's like d-day and [ __ ]
uh i've lost that one jesus christ
i need it i need to get inspired i don't
know i didn't know i was going to come
with an example
get a new piece of technology
i'm overheating man i'm sweating
get some antifreeze in this kid's ears
real quickly just have one of those
cookies
i know off a cookie
the tree trunk crust or the [ __ ]
or the cyanide icing i don't know those
things got a little bit of ether on them
[Music]
thank you for your patreon questions
keep submitting them yeah written review
sign up ian you got anything coming up
all right thanks so much
we love you good night
[Music]
into this camera
you can catch him blowing his roommate
ian
vampire electric i'm blocking
[Laughter]
high as [ __ ] right now sam what are you
doing to
us playlist check out ian's got a new
podcast
somewhere check him out on instagram
check him out in his office [ __ ]
cigarettes and talking to his cat
oh [ __ ] we should have stopped it and
andy freaks him
out somebody put antifreeze in this
guy's ears
guys go to patreon.com already garbage
rate reviews
wait i thought we were i was standing up
my stomach wouldn't have been hanging
out of this shirt
it doesn't cover it in the trunk we got
to get the plugs out
you got to get a bigger tarp
goddamn home depot
he's got to pay by the pound for his
clothes
all right got it cut it cut it
do your plugs come on you got to what do
you got coming up
he got covered up what do you got
gonna die i'm gonna have a seizure come
on get it out
spit it out where are you at tonight
you're gonna be the lamb out to rag man
what'd you have for lunch today
just stop i can't do it
[Laughter]
oh my everything hurts right now dude
holy [ __ ] all right guys go to
patreon.com
hey pick up a t-shirt will you
guys these clean living t-shirts are
available at podcastbirch.com
bald guys real stingy with the patreon
money [ __ ]
pick a sweatpants up or something the
kids are tanking over here
follow his stomach's hanging out he
needs surgery he tore his meniscus these
vests ain't cheap
actually they are shout out to walmart
yeah no one
i don't know that was a north face
looks like you cut two holes in a beach
blanket shout out to my new sponsor
eastfoot and everybody
oh that deserved more all right got it
all right
you know what now we're done goodbye
peace peace peace peace